The thing that will keep you going
through the hard times
is the fact that you really believe
in what you're doing.
So my first tip is find your passion.
Mumsnet took
a really long time to take off
in any business sense.
In those days, it was all about young
guys being invested in by young guys,
and here was I turning up,
a 30-year-old mum,
probably with some vomit
on my shoulder.
And I remember one guy said,
"I will invest in your business,
but only if someone else runs it."
And in fact that someone
was a 24-year-old man.
So I turned down his investment,
but actually,
you know, when you really
believe in something
that's what will keep you going
through the low moments.
So choose something
you have a real passion about,
because otherwise I think
it's too easy to give up.
My second tip is to make mistakes.
In fact, Mumsnet was born
out of a mistaken holiday.
It was my first holiday with kids
I knew nothing about it.
And I picked the wrong destination,
the wrong time zone,
the wrong resort. And it was
an unmitigated disaster -
and that was where the light bulb
moment for Mumsnet came.
Often the things that go wrong
can be the prompts
for what you can do right.
So my next tip is to wear trainers.
I think it's a brilliant way to fit
in exercise without going to the gym.
And it's a brilliant way to catch up
if you're running late.
There's also another part of this,
so don't feel,
as a women in business,
you have to spend hours
on your appearance.
Let's face it, Mark Zuckerberg wears
the same T-shirt and jeans every day,
and why should women
have a disadvantage?
And my final tip
is to embrace the chaos.
I think it's almost impossible
to fit in everything you want to
if you're trying to start
your own business
and you want to raise a family.
You have to embrace the fact
that you cannot be perfect.
But more importantly I think, it's
about not feeling guilty about stuff.
So my fourth child,
I cycled to his nursery,
with him in a seat on the back,
and he started singing
this lovely little tune to me.
He sang "Mummy, Mummy, Mummy, Mum,
Mummy, Mummy, don't got to work."
And, quite frankly,
if that had been my first children
I would have probably
been in tears on the pavement.
But you do get a bit wiser,
your kids will be fine,
and having guilt is a wasted emotion.
I think the thing that makes me
get up in the morning,
18 years on, and love coming
and doing what I do,
is I really quite like
finding solutions to things.
Being able to come to work
and collectively,
with a group of great people,
grapple with stuff
and try and find a solution
is something I find fascinating,
and it's what keeps me going really.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)